mesdames messieurs bon dimanche le
système judiciaire est-il devenu trop
permissif les remises en liberté sont
caution les peines d'emprisonnement à
domicile sont-elles trop courantes
ont-elles menées par exemple au meurtre
d'un policier ontarien par un délinquant
qui était en liberté en attendant la
tenue de son procès les premiers
ministres provinciaux et les chefs de
police du pays réclament des changements
au Code criminel et Ottawa se dit prête
à écouter
[Musique]
David l'amitié ministre de la Justice
procureur général du gouvernement
Trudeau merci d'être avec nous ça me
fait plaisir sur la médecine est-ce
qu'il y a des fêtes dans le Code
criminel qui font en sorte que des
criminels dangereux demeurent en liberté
c'est une question complexe c'est une
question qui a été soulevée au mois
d'octobre par les ministres la justice
et ministre sécurité publique lors de
réunion entre les provinces et nous
on a on a engagé en ce moment l'an
dernier de étudier le
les possibilités de porter des
changements au Code criminel mais c'est
complexe parce que oui on a la curation
de curcuminel au fédéral mais ce sont
les provinces les territoires qui ont
l'administration du système de la
libération mais les règles de Libération
les les règles prévoyant des peines
d'emprisonnement à domicile par exemple
elles viennent de vos modifications
législatives oui ça c'est vrai ici on
parle de la libération sous caution mais
il y a aussi beaucoup de jugements
là-dedans le jugement des juges pour
déterminer si une personne
pose une menace à la sécurité publique
parce qu'on a dans dans le système
on a le droit d'avoir la libération sous
caution c'est une droite protégée par la
Charte ainsi que par la cam maintenant
mais pour incarcéré quelqu'un
temporairement quelqu'un qui est
techniquement non coupable pour
l'instant il faut il faut une motivation
il faut que la personne pose une menace
et donc il y a beaucoup de jugements
là-dedans il y a aussi les policiers qui
doivent administrer
arrêter les personnes donc il y a
beaucoup de beaucoup de place pour
travailler avec les provinces pour
justement améliorer leur capacités vous
dites trois garanties par la Charte il y
a certains provinces qui disent ben on
devrait peut-être renverser le fardeau
de la preuve pour faire en sorte que les
gens par exemple prouvent qu'ils ne sont
pas dangereux afin d'être remises en
liberté c'est une option ça me semble
difficile on l'a déjà fait dans l'ancien
projet de loi c'est 75 pour les
questions de violence intime on a déjà
fait et ça existe déjà avec les armes à
feu évidemment on est on est prêt on l'a
dit aux provinces au territoire qu'on
est prêt à regarder d'autres options
d'autres infractions pour voir si on
peut le faire il y a la charte donc il
faut trouver l'équilibre en renversant
le fardeau faut rester à l'intérieur de
la Charte c'est une défi mais ce n'est
pas impossible vous avez dit cette
semaine ou la semaine dernière vous avez
dit que vous étiez prêt à agir mais que
les provinces devraient faire leur part
ça veut dire ça veut dire quoi qu'est-ce
qu'elle doit faire on doit travailler
ensemble donc oui on est prêt à regarder
ce que les provinces sont en train de
suggérer pour le changement que le
criminels mais comme je viens de dire il
y a l'administration du système et
s'ils ont besoin de plus de ressources
s'il y a d'autres changements qu'on
pourrait envisager des changements
techniques
on est prêt à travailler avec les
provinces mais mon message c'est qu'on
doit travailler ensemble c'est la raison
pour laquelle
j'ai annoncé que je vais convoquer une
réunion réunion spéciale
des ministres la justice et sécurité
publique justement pour regarder les
options et comment on pourrait mieux
faire ensemble à quelle vitesse d'après
vous un peut y avoir une réunion puis
deux il peut y avoir des modifications
pour pour tenter de remédier aux failles
qui ont été détectés par les provinces
je vais d'abord
je dirais dans les prochaines semaines
pour une réunion pour détecter les
feuilles on veut on voudrait avoir
les suggestions et la preuve des
provinces pourquoi la base pour leur
suggestions mais je crois que ça peut se
faire assez
vite
un foie qu'on se
réunisseurs conservatrices vous accusez
cette semaine
à plusieurs reprises d'avoir
assoupli ou d'avoir été un peu à la base
responsable de situation qu'on a vu
récemment à raison de modifications
législatives que vous avez adopté pour
être plus flexible pour avoir un Code
criminel plus flexible pour limiter
l'imposition de de peine minimale par
exemple pour les pour les juges est-ce
que à quel point est-ce que vous avez
une part de responsabilité dans tout ça
dans les deux cas si vous voulez le cas
des pains minimal c'est quelque chose à
côté mais pour la libération succession
ce qu'on a fait avec le projet de loi
165 c'est incorporer l'édition de la
course prime du Canada on a comme je
viens de dire on a renversé le fardeau
de la preuve dans les cas de violence
intime et donc on a on a rendu le
système plus difficile dans plusieurs
cas pour les les
crimes graves donc ça me permet des
peines à domicile par exemple ça c'est
une autre question oui ça c'est notre
projet de loi c'est 5 là le but c'est
vraiment de de
désengorger le système parce que on
consacre trop de ressources pour les
infractions
qui sont sérieuses mais qui ne sont pas
aussi graves que d'autres infractions et
on veut consacrer plus de ressources
justement pour les infractions graves
l'idée d'exclure les peines avec sursis
pour les crimes sexuels c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait être étudié on vient
de les on vient de redonner la
possibilité avec
une peine avec sourcil et là justement
pour des cas où la personne ne pose pas
une menace à la société et une procureur
à la évidemment la responsabilité de
fournir la preuve dans le sens contraire
c'est une c'est une moyenne de combattre
le sur une conservation des peuples
autochtones les POP noir racisées dans
le système statistiquement c'est vrai et
ça donne la possibilité d'une certaine
flexibilité ou la personne ne peut comme
et je dois le souligner ne pose pas une
menace à la société et la peine arrêté
moins de deux ans les infractions graves
mériteront toujours les conséquences
graves dans le système et le juge a tout
le temps la possibilité de donner le
maximum
vous avez déposé la semaine dernière
jeudi dernier projet de loi pour
repousser l'aide médicale à mourir pour
les personnes souffrant de troublement
manteau d'un an vous êtes il faut qu'on
se prépare davantage il y a des gens qui
souffrent de trop de manteau qui eux
disent ça retarde encore l'accès à un
service que l'on attend depuis des
années vous leur dites quoi ces gens je
suis de tout cœur avec eux je comprends
qu'ils sont en train de souffrir les
comme société nous avons beaucoup
compris les dernières beaucoup
amélioré nos connaissances si on veut
des maladies mentales
ce que je ce que je dois faire en tant
que ministre c'est de s'assurer que la
société est prête pour cette étape on a
eu l'encadrement donné par le comité
d'experts
de Montréal qui a présidé le Comité elle
pense qu'on est prête
mais il y avait certaines provinces qui
ont des noms on n'est pas prêt
ou bien certaines facultés certaines
universités d'autres experts qui ont dit
on n'est pas prêt donc c'est le temps
justement pour
internaliser l'encadrement qui a été
donné par la loi et par le comité des
experts de développer les guides de
développer les matériaux didactiques
et puis j'espère dans une Anne nous
serons tous dans une classe où on va
respirer par le nez et on va dire ok on
est prêt vous dites quoi aux gens qui
disent que le simplement fédéral je suis
comme un peu à la pression politique il
y a des gens qui sont pas d'accord avec
l'idée d'aller jusque là dans l'Aide
médicale à mourir ils l'ont fait
entendre il le disent à votre
gouvernement est-ce qu'il y a une
pression est-ce que vous sortez une
pression
dans la vie publique dans la politique
il faut écouter les gens donc je suis en
train d'écouter non seulement les
personnes avec qui je suis en accord
mais aussi les gens qui sont dans des
accords avec moi avec nous avec nos
gouvernements c'est une devoir je le
fais d'une façon responsable mais on
procède avec la loi après avoir écouté
les gens et après avoir écouté les
experts on procède avec la loi d'une
façon aussi prudente et c'est ce qu'on
est en train de faire on a mis une pause
d'une heure
mais ce n'est qu'une pause